In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadion for June 14th, on which we commemorate the Holy Prophet
Alayshah.
The Holy Prophet Alayshah, whose name means God is salvation, was the Son of a rich farmer
of Abel Mahola in the Jordan Valley.
One day, as he was working with twelve pairs of oxen, the Holy Prophet Alayshah went
up to him and threw his mantle over him, signifying by this act that he had chosen him
as his disciple and the inheritor of his prophetic charisma.
Alayshah slaughtered two of the oxen and used their yolks to burn them as an offering to the
Lord.
Then, renouncing everything and without even taking leave of his family, he followed Alayshah
and became his devoted servant.
When Alayshah had completed his mission, Alayshah insisted on following him to the place where
he was to be taken up into heaven, and he asked his master to leave him a double portion of
his spirit as an inheritance.
A chariot of fire appeared, and Alayshah was taken up to heaven in a whirlwind, letting
his mantle fall to the earth.
Alayshah took it up and returned to stand on the bank of the Jordan.
He struck the waters and invoked the God of Alayshah, and the waters divided to one side
and to the other, so that Alayshah was able to pass through dryshod.
The assembly of the prophetic brothers then came to prostrate before him, saying, the spirit
of Alayshah has rested on Alayshah.
Alayshah followed his prophetic ministry for some fifty years, 850-800 BC, in the kingdom
of Samaria, during the reigns of Joram, Jehu, Jehoahaz, and Joash.
He, untiringly, exhorted the Israelites, both the kings, the nobles, and the humble people,
to turn from the foreign gods Baal and Astarti, and to return to the worship of the one true
God.
The legend prophets preached through words and visions, others through their sufferings
and tribulations.
Alayshah, like his master, manifested the truth of his preaching by miracles.
The spirit of God was with him as a power, which reversing the laws of nature witnessed
to the grace given to those who adhere to the true God, thus prefiguring the work of
the Savior.
The prophet cleansed with salt the waters of the fountain near Jericho, multiplied the oil
of a poor widow so that she could pay her debts, transformed a bitter broth into a delicious soup
to feed the prophetic brotherhood, and multiplying twenty Barley loaves was able to feed more
than a hundred people.
Each time he passed through Shunam, the prophet was given hospitality there by a wealthy woman.
One day, the son she had been given through the prayers of Alayshah died.
She rushed to find the prophet on Mount Carmel and implored him to return with her to the
dead boy.
Alayshah found him stretched out on his own bed, and, while the miracle could have been accomplished
solely by his prayer, he stretched himself on the child, putting his mouth on the child's
mouth, his eyes on the eyes of the child, his hands on his hands, and he breathed into him
the breath of life.
By this act, the prophet prefigured the incarnation of our Lord Jesus Christ, who descended from
heaven, configuring himself to the measure of the human creature who was dead through sin,
and breathed his spirit of eternal life into him.
Afterwards, Alayshah persuaded the same Shunamite to flee the kingdom of Israel in order to
escape a famine there which was to last for seven years.
On another occasion, one of the prophetic brotherhood, who was working next to the Jordan, let
the head of his axe fall into the river.
Alayshah took a piece of wood and threw it into the river at the spot where the axe had fallen,
and the axe rose up out of the water, thus prefiguring the power of the cross, which raises
up fallen human nature.
Enlightened by the grace of God, Alayshah's gaze was so penetrating that it revealed the
plans of the king of Assyria to the kings of Israel and their allies.
Each time the former tried to prepare an ambush against the Israelites, he would find them
ready in place and prepared to fight.
In Samaria, which was under siege from the Syrians and was being starved into submission,
the man of God announced to the king who was ready to blaspheme against God that help was
close at hand and that they would be delivered.
The next day they discovered that the enemy army had retreated after having been subjected
to a terrifying vision, leaving behind all its provisions and an immense amount of booty.
Not content with prophesying to the Israelites, the prophet Alayshah also exercised his ministry
among the pagans.
He prophesied the assassination of Ben Hadad, king of Damascus, by his officer, Hazael, and
told the latter that he would seize power.
On another occasion he healed Naman, the general of the Syrian army who had become a leper
ordering him to go and wash himself in the Jordan, thus prefiguring the salvation of the pagans
by holy baptism.
Yet the grace of God also acted through him to punish sin.
When children mocked the prophet and, when the latter cursed them, two bears came out
of a wood and tore apart forty-two of them.
When his servant Gehazi wished to steal the presence that Naman had sent to the prophet
as a sign of his gratitude, he was unable to escape the piercing gaze of his master and
became leprous.
Through all the startling actions accomplished by God through his prophet, the kingdom of
Israel was almost entirely purified from the cult of Baal.
But the Jews, guilty of having broken the unity of the kingdom, needed continual divine interventions
to make them turn from idols and sin and return to the worship of the true God.
The holy prophet Alayshah died at a great old age after having prophesied to the king
of Israel who had come to his bedside to mourn his loss that he would conquer the Syrians.
That year a dead man who had been thrown into the prophet's tomb came to life again and
was able to stand on his feet.
This is why Syrak, the sage, praised the prophet in these words.
And after his death, his body prophesied.
His tomb, after having been held in great esteem by the Jews, was violated under Julian the
apostate in 362.
But fragments of the prophet's relics may have been transferred to Alexandria and Constantinople,
where a church was dedicated to him.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us and
save us.